But, but, but, here another thing,
though. Like, I I bodyguard this guy who
was a pimp before, and he told me, he
said, "Look, if a man have too much of
one thing, he start trying other
things." So, as soon as I heard that, I
went celibate for like 2 years. And
then, in the music industry, you see a
lot of things that's evil.
Did you guys know the definition of
emergency is a serious situation that
requires immediate action? Imagine your
loved ones under rubble in a earthquake,
or bombs being dropped in Gaza, or in
Yemen, or in Afghanistan where there's
an earthquake. Brothers and sisters,
we're working with One Ummah to get
immediate relief to those who are in
need. Please go to the link and donate
whatever you can, inshallah, and let
this be a sadaqah jariyah that you was
for your you was there for your brothers
and sisters when they needed you.
As-salamu alaykum. Welcome to this
reaction video. There's been some mad
stuff happening with Puff Daddy in the
news and the trafficking stuff and him
getting arrested in the hotel lobby. You
can see the footage of him, and then all
of his entourage just like, you know,
they just go in a different direction.
Then, the him being that woman and all
this weird and you really know these
people, I mean, you know these rappers
and we were talking about this earlier,
you know, all this satanic stuff in the
music industry. Um and so, now we're
going to be looking at what one of his
one of these bodyguards is actually
saying what happens at these crazy
parties. But, what's your thoughts on
the madness, though? I'll be honest, I I
had no idea what was going on until
Zeeshan was telling me it's like some
stuff. And then, you and then people
start talking about it. I was like, "I
don't know what's going on." But, I'll
be honest with you, though,
people deleting I had no idea what was
going on. But, after you sent me this
thing this this video
his bodyguard was like really funny,
guys. This is where
Funny being funny aside, you're going to
see some of the funny bits, but on a
serious note, guys, it's like these
people with their lifestyle so satanic.
Like, it's it's it's crazy. And you you
don't need to be honest, it's not like
something far-fetched when you hear this
stuff the stuff he's about to tell us.
Yeah. But, now he's in a prison cell,
and it's one of the most dirtiest prison
cells, you know. Yeah. Imagine from that
lifestyle. This this shows you, you
know, it reminds me watch this. But,
it's like when Allah says, you know, in
the Quran, "How long did you live on
Earth?" And it's like, "Oh, we lived a
day or day and a half." Yeah.
If this comes to if it's true and he's
going to be sentenced, it's all gone,
bro. You're going to spend the rest of
your life Well, even right now. Yeah.
Even right now, just just being away
from all of that. Yeah. But, you know,
here's the thing. He's in his 50s. You
know, how much longer does he want He's
been doing it in his 20s and 30s and
partying and whatever. The human soul is
never satisfied with anything except on
when you die. Yeah. So, you end up doing
mad stuff. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Let's
watch this and then afterwards we're
going to give some really powerful
reminders. I think it's very important
for you guys who are trying to chase
this lifestyle, etc. Yeah, I mean, I I
lived the life
nothing close to this. I would be like
Bro, let's let's hope not.
I used to be like I used to listen to
this guy in the clubs, bro. Yeah. The
thing we remember going to a Diddy
party, all the waitresses topless. They
serving you, everybody topless, you feel
me? Like, you got dancers in cages,
people walking around with lions on
leashes tigers on leashes. I seen this
with my own two eyes. You see what I'm
saying? And it was getting so weird in
the party. I'm like, man, Bobby
Valentino was the person I was
bodyguarding there. You see what I'm
saying? He tell me, "I didn't got so
much [__] before, you know, don't even
really excite me." I'm like, "What you
mean?" But, he there. What you mean?
On bro, folks grave. I said, "What you
mean?" So, he got two girls with him.
So, I'm thinking to myself like, "Damn,
hold on. These might not be normal
girls." Sure enough. Now, he say, "Man,
take my girl to the bathroom." I'm like,
"Okay." We walking to the bathroom, you
feel me? She go into the men's bathroom.
But, that's that's not all the way crazy
cuz if one bathroom packed, you feel me?
People might do that. You know what I'm
saying? So, people start swarming the
door. So, I step inside the bathroom,
though. She standing at the urinal.
Dress lifted up. I'm like, "Damn." Okay,
that's how they coming? But, but, but,
here another thing, though. Like, I I
bodyguard this guy who was a pimp
before, and he told me, he said, "Look,
if a man have too much of one thing, he
start trying other things." So, as soon
as I heard that, I went celibate for
like 2 years. And then, in the music
industry, you see a lot of things that's
evil. And they will tell you you crazy
cuz you won't agree with it. I've seen
this. And what was your actual
interaction with Diddy like? So, my
interactions with him was this. He had a
he had a appearance at this club called
The Vibe in Chicago on Kingsbury when it
was open. I was head of security at this
club. So, after that club closed, after
the night was over, he had an
after-party. So, the manager of the club
said, "I need you to come with me to the
after-party." So, me and my other homie,
we go to the after-party. When we get to
the after-party, bro, like, it was a lot
of females in there who are who stand up
when they use the bathroom. You see what
I'm saying? So, I'm thinking to myself
like, man, like, this is this this kind
of wild, on bro. Like, this how y'all
coming? This how you If this how y'all
live, how y'all live. But, they want to
keep it a secret. He real touchy-feely,
too. Like, he grabbed this he grabbed
this other guy nobody's neck. Grabbed
him by his neck and was like, "Do you
have love in your heart, young man? You
want to be a road? Do you want to walk
with God?" I'm looking like, "You going
to let him grab you like that?" But,
then, you know, he be on some tough guy
[__] too. So, I guess he a tough
case. So, you know, like they out there
having a dude come out with the paper
sign an NDA. Now, I'm going to the car,
bro. I'm good. I'm not signing no NDA.
I'm going to the car. I'm good. Seeing
that, bro. So, seeing all this coming in
the news, people was telling me I was
crazy. Said I was a hater. Hey, no what?
I don't want to party with the girls
with the with the third leg, man. I'm
good. What do you think about them
accusing Diddy of having cameras in his
house so he could record celebrities and
politicians and use it as blackmail? So,
I firmly believe that's true because in
that sector of people, a lot of them
practice Scientology. And Scientology,
that was their thing. They would get
people in compromising positions, they
would hold that footage over their head,
and get them to agree to things. So,
like, you know what If you Okay, if you
see somebody with the chain on with that
little vial of blood on their neck,
well, they a Scientologist, bro. So,
it's definitely going to be footage of
them somewhere doing something
compromising. That's how a lot of these
agreements get made. People get
endorsed. How they get that deal? I
don't know what. As soon as he was
talking, I was thinking I was thinking I
was thinking of Epstein. I was thinking
of Epstein. Now, we don't know how
what's going on. So, obviously you got
this bodyguard, you got all this stuff
that he's saying. There's other people
coming out with crazy stuff, lots of
accusations. What we do know is he's
been arrested. There's certain things
which are really, really mad. For sure,
Madonna and all bunch a whole bunch of
these celebrities in the past, they're
doing things which are satanic. They're
doing things of a sexual nature. You
know,
if you do not have a belief in a
religion which stops you in terms of uh
you know, certain things being
prohibited, what what's there to stop
you? Your nafs is your God. You're going
to, you know, try and make yourself the
happiest person. You're not going to be
pleased with anything, and then you're
going to become more perverted over
time. And some of this stuff is just
crazy if you think about it. It's like
that, man. I mean, it's
it's it's like that, bro. I mean, like,
many people, you know, of course it
depends, you know, if you have someone
who has principles. But, again, you
know, it's it's so hard not to be
influenced, you know. That's why I say
you're either going to be influenced by
the creation or be influenced by the
creator.
That's the reason why, you know, a lot
of people in the West like myself chose
to be influenced by the creator cuz we
realized being influenced by the
creation of Allah says in the Quran it's
like Have you seen the one parable Have
you seen the one who has multiple
masters compared to one? When you have
multiple masters, each one is giving you
a different direction. You're being
influenced in different ways. When you
have one master, it's just so simple.
When I came to Islam, the matter was so
clear to me. I knew instructions of how
to wear, what to eat, what not to eat,
when to pray, what not to do. That was
it. But, when I was not Muslim, I there
was so much things. I was like, "What
should I do?" You know, you got the the
you got the peer pressure, you know,
trying to be you know, trying to appease
the opposite gender, trying to live a
specific lifestyle. I lived that to a
certain extent. Nothing as crazy as
these people. And I knew where's my soul
where my soul could have gone. You know,
I I thought to myself like a couple of
months ago. I was saying to myself, "If
I was still doing the same thing of
clubbing and partying, I genuinely
believe either a mental hospital, either
suicidal I would have killed myself, or
I I would have been the most miserable
person walking this
ended up at the P Diddy party. I mean, I
I
I would have to reject that, you know.
Non-disclosure. That guy said, "I'm
going to go wait in the car." So, the
thing is non-disclosure agreement. And
And what he said is very true because
the thing is you need to understand as
human beings Allah subhana wa ta'ala
says in the Quran that he's he's put
everything created everything with a
balance. Everything is measured, bro.
What that means is our desires and
everything has a certain cap on it. When
when you go past that, of course you're
going to have these tendencies of, "You
know what? Let me There was this one guy
I was watching. He was someone who was
obviously slept with prostitutes or
prostitutes. He's there and he's
testifying. He's saying, "I was sitting
there." He goes, "I'm just like bored.
I've I've slept with all of these
women." And then, he he sees a a a
prostitute who is deaf. And he goes,
"I've never been with a deaf one." And
he goes, "I just want to experience
having intimacy with a woman that's
deaf." This is how perverted you become
because you're just like, "Hmm, I never
tried that." Oh, then you go move on to
animals. Bro, you move to animals.
Because the thing is when do you stop?
And nothing will ever fill the son of
Adam's stomach except
And one thing that's really important is
this.
Life goes so fast, bro. Yeah? Millions
of people, billions, maybe trillions of
people me and like me and you lived on
this Earth, walked on this Earth how
we're speaking like right now, have
talked about death and what's going to
happen to us, and they are gone. The
point is this, bro, that when Allah says
we're going to live in this Earth for a
couple of days. I just want you to
imagine P Diddy had all of those sex and
all that kind of stuff. Yeah. If you
guys are watching and you're into it
like, "Oh, I want to have all this kind
of stuff." Yeah, okay. Just imagine he
for about He's 50 years old. For about
maybe 25, 30, maybe 35 years in of his
life, he had any woman he wants. He's
done God knows what.
You cannot even imagine. It all came to
an end. Now, from here onwards, it's
going to be a prison cell. If this is
true that he's going to be sentenced
whatever it is it's true. Yeah? He's
going to be in a prison in a little box.
Yeah? For the rest of his life. When he
dies, you wish he ends there. Now, it's
the hereafter. The question we need to
ask is the following. Was it worth it?
35 years of pleasure that's all gone
now. Now, you're in the moment. You're
in the prison cell. If you're going to
get done, you're going to get sentenced
sentenced or God knows maybe life in
prison. After you die, now you're going
to be questioned by the creator. The
creation's punishing you. Then, it's
going to be the creator. Eternity or
maybe like depends obviously if he
believes in God, that's a different
story, etc. But, is it worth spending
eternity? I mean, do any calculation get
any
calculator, bro. Divide any kind of
finite amounts of time, 30 years, 70, 80
years by infinity. It's in it's not
worth it. It is not And not only if you
if you look at that, if you look at what
does he cherish in this life?
Yeah. He's all about his crew and people
around him. Yeah. Now, what happened
when he got arrested? You see in the
We're going to have the footage there,
right? They just walk away from him.
Done. You got people that he paid like
security guards or whatever saying, "Oh,
I saw this. I saw that." Where Who's
there for you? So, your whole life your
narrative is about it's me and my boys
and it's me and my career. Okay, who's
there with you? Who's Who's in prison
sentence for you? Who's willing to
rescue you? Nobody. And they walk his
entourage is walking in the hub in the
lobby. He gets arrested, they walk away.
Yeah, of course. They just casually Do
you think they care about him? That's
the reason why we say brother and
sister, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala was
there for you before your creation, when
you was created, when you was born, when
you live, when you die, when you're
resurrected again. Brother and sisters,
every step of the way, there's no Allah.
That's why if you put Allah before
anybody, Allah will humiliate you with
that very thing, very with that
creation. Okay? So, put Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala first. These people are
violent individuals, sadly. I mean, you
lifestyle is You cannot make this stuff
up, man.
It is so disgusting the lifestyle. And
believe me, it will destroy. Bro,
this is crazy, bro. I don't even know
what to say. I mean, you
[Music]
It fits, bro. But before before we come
to an end, Ali, it fits the pattern. It
fits what we've been hearing about this
stuff that's been going on for decades.
All of this weird stuff and their
cultish stuff and satanic stuff that the
music industry they have these
particular verses that they play
backwards and they do this and they do
that. There's a guy I met There's a guy
actually you know him. I know him. This
particular brother, he's somebody
involved in in terms of filming and
stuff like this in the da'wah. He was
telling me of somebody that he knows
that's close to a Hollywood star. I'm
not going to say who the Hollywood star
is, but direct evidence of this. He was
walking into his house one day and he
saw that the shahada was on a doormat.
Wow. He's thinking, "What?" Can you ask
this guy like, "What's this thing doing
here?" And the guy said, "Oh, I was
gifted this." It's like, "What's going
on?" You get You going to get You get
the disrespect of the Islamic things
because at the end of the day, it is all
satanic. It is all there is an There's
an alternative view to Islam they're
trying to push and now they're getting
exposed. But do you know what? He's
gone, right? In a way like he's in jail,
whatever. There's a dozens of these
people out there.
Loads of them and they're going to going
to
going to get up to even more depraved
things because the human soul is never
going to be satisfied. Yeah, exactly.
You know, it's like that. Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah for Islam, man. You know,
the degeneracy was going in the West and
the West is turning to Islam. They're
realizing atheism and hedonistic
lifestyle is not the way. So, brother
and sisters, look, you know, smart is
the one who learns from somebody else's
mistake, you know, wise or something
along those lines. But the thing is
learning from other people's mistakes is
important. It's very
important because if you can do
yourself, but for you to learn from
somebody who's done it, it's a big
lesson. And if you don't, you know,
subhanallah, you know, and and Allah
there's there's a verse in the Quran
I'll probably put in the bottom. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says, you know, that
he sends signs and signs to his
servants. And when his servant carries
on transgressing and transgressing, and
Allah says that when he thinks he's
reached his peak, it was that's when we
snatch his soul. You know, when you
think you Allah sending you signs, don't
do haram, don't do haram. You're getting
those signs and you know it's from
Allah. And you just carry on cuz you are
into your desires. Allah says we open
the doors of everything for them. And
when they reach their peak thinking I am
untouchable, like you did it. He goes,
"We snatch their soul." So, at least
people do this so they got a chance of
maybe repenting and changing his ways.
But yeah, that's it, brother and
sisters. I hope you guys have enjoyed
this video. Inshallah. In the meantime,
also don't forget brother and sisters to
check out brother Suboor's channel as
well, inshallah. The base discussions
and many other things that pertain to
evolution, you know, check inshallah.
We'll put the link there, inshallah, in
the bottom. Whoever turns away from
Allah's remembrance will have a
depressed life. And in the remembrance
of Allah do hearts find peace. That's
the best way of ending. Salaam Alaikum
wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.